sometimes i just do stuff
what's up everybody this is donald
mitchell with the utah jazz i'm about to
give you guys a behind-the-scenes look
at what happens on the floor on the
breakdown the way our team is set up you
know you have a dynamic role in rudy
gobert you have mike conley who's you
know
past first point guard who can also
score he got a bunch of shooters around
us and royce o'neill boy yeah about
donovan so for myself being the guy who
can typically create off the dribble
get guys shots you know off of a rudy
screen get downhill but also create
shots for myself i think it's the
perfect fit with the group we have jimmy
was on me to start you know and there
was a screen set i passed ahead to mike
rudy rolls trying to look at rudy
initially on the roll you see it right
there and nothing so then we respace and
typically there are a few teams that do
this miami you know they're great at
trapping you know and kind of helping
each other uh so mike beats pj
forcing them to help
my space since i've become a good
shooter from three it forces them to
have to close out hard which allows me
to get downhill i get by bam now i'm at
the rim once pj leaves i get by duncan's
reach i don't see anybody so i'm just
going right up
and rudy being the lab threat he is
jimmy's not going to come over and help
that's why i have to live seeing that i
shoot 65 within five feet of the rim you
know it shows that the work i've
continuously put in over the summers of
my finishing was really coming out and
really showing throughout the season and
i've been putting the work in and to see
it come to light i think is pretty
special but there's definitely a room to
grow for sure once you see me get the
ball on the mother floor i kind of go to
the left wing i get here to kind of
assess
where al horford's at you know i'm not
worried about marcus smart because
one-on-one from that far out is tough
for even it for the really good defender
once i see rudy come in i say okay i'm
going to use the screen
smart is good so he beats me to the top
so i tried to pull it back if you see
the blog kind of lose it for a second
that's me trying to snatch it back to my
legs but i lose it so now i'm keeping my
dribble alive i don't know as stroder
until probably
[Music]
i would say here
and then i'm like alright let me just
find a way to just dribble it out and
then i saw the opening on the right side
and marcus's feet shift all i needed was
smart's feet to shift
he jumps to his right my left and allows
me to get downhill and this goes back to
my summer finishing just finishing over
the top finishing through contact
sometimes my job is to make tough lips
making the defense work and continuously
creating advantages is definitely what
we pride ourselves on we had played in
sacramento
a few weeks prior
and i never played against davion
typically in the nba guys aren't as
aggressive as he is you know he's strong
he's quick he's fast he's athletic in
the sense he's able to keep up
typically with aggressive defenders they
want to beat you to the screen and beat
you over
so understanding that i gave him the jab
with my left foot to loosen him a little
bit to see what he's going to do
and with that with that jab if you look
at his right foot his right foot goes to
a point where he tries to stop me from
going that way
and then he tries to beat me to the spot
which allows me to counter it
and get into a one-two for my shot
there's three different ways to shoot a
pull-up
left right
right left
or hop and this one's just left right
with my pull-ups being at 3.6 made per
game for work is huge your base
uh weightlifting you know getting your
legs strong so you can shoot from
different distances in this clip in
particular being able to counter it and
still get to my proper footwork i think
it's just the biggest thing i work on
each summer once i get to the spin as
long as i get to that right there that's
the same thing as walking into it doing
left right so when i do a drill it's
dribble left right dribble left right
you shoot that same shot over and over
again so it doesn't matter how you get
to that the footwork is going to always
be the same with me averaging 2.8
driving kicks to a three point per game
i draw so much attention on my drives
that now you have 40 percent 40 40 it's
a matter of who shoots it people want to
stay with rudy
and then
it opens up shots for everybody else and
allows allows us to kind of you know get
into our what we call jazz basketball
moving the ball i prefer the double team
because we have such good shooting you
know it's like all right go ahead take
me out to play we're gonna either get a
three or one of our bigs at the rim uh
for a dunk being able to have guys who
shoot 40
and then have rudy roll in the way it
does it's really just a matter of
picture poison and executing rudy does a
great job by flashing he makes a move
they help
he hits trent so now i know i have six
seconds
um if ant is one step slower i'm
shooting this but he runs me off the
line doing his job
um because i'd hit a few threes already
in the first quarter and now it's like
okay what do you want me to do patrick
beverly would stay there but it's his
misassignment if jc gets a three so you
bet you pass fake to get him out the
equation now nathan knight not going to
help because it's an easy rudy love so
now it's a matter of who's going to help
either i have a layup which they don't
want me to get or i have a uh a three
noel helps so now rudy's respacing to
the corner
um knowing that he's in the corner and i
know if i can get it there he's gonna be
able to take that shot the nba card
optics allows you to get a different
perspective of the game you know allows
you to understand you know you have the
physical game where you play but then
you also have the numbers that you know
go along to it i think it's great that
fans having access to it now and it's
only going to continue to build and get
more and get better and better
appreciate you watching the breakdown
with me shout out to bleacher report and
nba court optics